[Music]
time now for our morning rounds our look
at the medical news of the week
according to the American Cancer Society
nearly 29 thousand men will die this
year from prostate cancer this week
updated screening guidelines for
prostate cancer were published in the
Journal of the American Medical
Association with some notable changes
from previous editions here to discuss
some of the updates is CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus who joins us
bright and early from Los Angeles David
thanks for getting up so early this
morning
I am up Anthony let's talk about what
are some of the most prominent changes
here David well in 2012 the US
Preventive task force said nobody should
be screened for PSA testing the data
didn't merit it and now when studying
Europe with longer follow-up is showing
clear survival to the people who were
tested and so they changed the
recommendations so that people aged 55
to 69 now should talk to their doctors
so it's a discussion with your doctor
about whether you should be tested or
not based on your own value system the
problem is there's some false positives
so not everybody should be tested but
the discussion should happen 55 to age
69 David dr. Angus the New England
Journal also found this week and that
same topic they released a study that
looked at the use of MRIs for that
screening what did it find it's so cool
right Wednesday the US Preventive task
force said we have a problem with
biopsies too many false positives but we
have to do it cuz the save some some
lives the next day the New England
Journal of Medicine has an article I've
got a better way to do biopsies showing
that if you do an MRI and know where to
stick the needle you get fewer false
positive you find the more aggressive
cancers and fewer people need biopsies
so in advance happened the next day
pretty exciting David these these false
positives are really scary I had one I
mean there's nothing more terrifying is
it I mean is it really possible to have
a test that's essentially foolproof for
this not even close you know what we
know is that since we started screening
the death rate has died of prostate
cancer so I'm a believer in screening
people say have you been tested and I
say you know yes I am tested
but you know I feel for what you went
through a false-positive is a scary
thing but also getting an aggressive
prostate cancer that has left the
prostate is also very scary alright our
next topic a form of injury that impacts
older Americans at an alarming rate it's
falling a new report from the CDC is
bringing more attention to the issue in
fact one in four Americans aged 65 and
older report falling every year this
accounts for the largest percentage of
unintentional deaths moreover there are
roughly three million fall related
emergency room visits annually
dr. Angus when you hear those numbers I
guess what can you tell us about why
this keeps happening why there's been
with increased it's a staggering amount
of statistics right you know 18 thousand
deaths in 2007 close to 30,000 deaths in
2016 so people are getting older there
are more medicines and the medicines can
er act interact make it harder to you
know to walk especially at night when
you go up and go to the bathroom there
are more blood thinners and at the same
time we need to counsel patients better
because this is a preventable cause of
death but those statistics the death
rate rising 3 percent or so a year is
really worrisome David are there
specific risks risk factors that you can
look at that indicate it's more likely
for this to happen to somebody no
question about it so multiple medicines
being on a blood thinner for example if
you have atrial fibrillation or an
irregular heartbeat and a blood thinner
you hit your head you can get a bleed
you know people who urinate a lot at
night is a risk factor you get up at
night you're a little bit disoriented
it's dark you can trip and you know
people who have it difficult to engage
so as a doctor I have to say you know do
you have any trouble walking and I have
to assess their stability and also look
at the medicines are on and try to
counsel them so that I can try to
prevent a fall and finally dr. agus we
get an assist from the technology area
simple activities like eating and
getting dressed are something most
people don't think about but for those
who have dementia it can be a real
struggle researchers at NYU Arizona
State and the MGH Institute of Health
Professions recently unveiled a self
dressing system assisted by smart
technology for track
ding guidance and recognition it's
designed to allow people with dementia
to get dressed on their own each item of
clothing has bar coded information that
verifies that the garment has been put
on correctly a caregiver can start and
monitor the system using an app the
system known as dress is in the
prototype stage but developers caution
more tweaks are needed before it heads
to the market still that's incredibly
encouraging it's great I mean it's very
hard for caregivers the dress especially
when you're of different sexes and so
this is something that will ease some of
their fears and the technology is
exciting the data in this study were you
know really impressive and need a little
bit of improvement but this is something
that's gonna help a lot of people dr.
David agus thank you so much for joining
us this morning thank you guys